um well you know um staying on a tractor
for a long time did not prepare you for
being in the desert for a long time
because I did see you post something
that I thought was awesome watch us
it is 105 degrees outside I got the air
conditioner on and I'm still hot like
the back of my neck is hot I don't even
know where that come from
now I'm coming up on a ridge
if I get over this damn Ridge
best not be no more damn desert
how to Desert this damn thing
[Applause]
so I don't even I don't even think I
have to ask you where you're driving
because there is because I've driven
from Texas to California many times and
there is a stretch is that where you
were kind of coming from Arkansas to
California it was it was Flagstaff to
California oh my God and there's if you
don't stop there's one thing if you
don't stop for gas yeah I stopped forget
well I have a really cool hybrid car
smelling stuff for grass three times oh
that's awesome yeah but but yeah I
stopped for gas like in the desert and
that's like after that video I was like
it is so hot out here yeah what is going
on but I was driving to I drove from
Arkansas I picked up the car in Arkansas
and I drove from Arkansas to Los Angeles
and I was driving out here to do the
show The Grand Cru oh my gosh that's so
awesome that's so very cool so did you
did you swear off road trips from Road
Rules were you just like done I like to
get naked in a hot tub don't worry about
it justice do you say naked uh I say I
say naked oh see actually that's
it if you use it in a sentence I came in
and he was naked that's that's kind of
country if I came in and he was naked
that's yeah you're right
[Applause]
right
I was like that one sounds more country
to me you were like you know what never
mind
[Music]